tec-9 bootleg care voy yo it's wild 94 1
the base party station man bootleg keV
here Ready Set Radio and in studio
special guests tec-9 tec-9 in the
building yes sir brother what's good bro
we're all over the world doing this man
bye
I'm telling you I'll see him all in the
world like in every town I wouldn't be
surprised if I saw him in Canada next
time we going or Australia I think they
say we doing
Hawaii finally after all these years oh
wow so the bumping see you there - first
time in Hawaii
yeah is gonna be my first that's gonna
be dope man um so you're on tour like I
feel like every six months is about yeah
we sitting at home every what is about
usually like every nine months no no no
we do like three three tours a year man
so because you got a you guys think this
tour started like six days ago 78 dates
right then we get back we have to
service Canada I think and then
Australia and then Europe so it's like
we try to do that every year we try to
you know I'm saying could always take a
big vacation at the end of the year of
course you know saying we go to
Caribbean and just chill get hoppin we
get the biggest rooms on the on the
Royal Caribbean and on the Disney cruise
man last last last New Year's Eve we had
I had the Roy Disney sweetie at the Walt
Disney you know saying nice we do it
real big for our families man you know
I'm sizzling cuz we work so much and so
hard for our fans you know I'm sizzling
yeah um so we're just talking off the
air about the the fragile record which
you know there's been out for a long
time now but it's finally breaking it
just hit top 20 on rhythmic radio I was
so crazy to me it's growing man people
are really rockin with it like whoo it's
been a while since you've really had a
song on the radio like that I remember I
don't recall ever having a song in a
video like that yeah I think that the
last time I heard a song when I started
as an intern way back in the day in
Phoenix I think we were playing here
comes Tekken eNOS oh-oh here comes
second either that's crazy and overnight
we weren't we were we were pushing that
too back then and I'm saying yeah but I
mean it's it's like seriously like it's
like a long time coming because you're
such a huge figure in hip hop in a boy
in your own right below how's it feel
mandated to be on the other side now
kinda when I get those reports from
politicking and how many ads we get
daily and stuff like that or weekly you
know I mean and then they started
sending me the Shazam number yeah but
people are actually Shazam in like who
was that like they don't know what tech
9 is I'm flabbergasted because I've been
doing it for so many years but it has
been an underground thing and to make a
song that you didn't think was gonna be
played on radio you just do music that
you feel that you love and that you got
a chip on your shoulder on this song
yeah if somebody said something crazy
you know to have that being played man
as a victory man yeah beautiful for the
people who don't know the inspiration
behind the verse you're obviously
talking to critics but is it a specific
creative what what yeah is never a
critic man who said something after my
pay dues performance last year he said
although tec-9 can be redundant and
gimmicky oh he said redundant to the cat
that makes different music every time he
writes under patina I'm saying but I had
to try to put it in perspective why
would he say that after seeing my
performance he gots to know that I'm oh
gee I have cycles like yeah I got it
Midwest choppers one I got my own world
watch shop yeah so he might have saw the
choppers area well put them all together
and it's odd think I think I think of
that might be redundant to him but he
don't know he's talking to a og watch
your mouth for one Oh No then he said
gimmicky my face paint I try to put it
in perspective gimmicky my dad homeboy
Brian Dennis painted my face in 94 and
in and in honor of him I wear my face
paint every night you calling a gimmicky
I want to fight right so fragile came
back Fredrick came out some of the
people appointed to give him the pinning
you never do get it I want you to come
on gobble Jimmy and da minha be given
the remedy my critics are really the
enemy and I can't stand the way they
slam today's gifted you know say I'm
going at them you know I mean but it's
so fast that people like ooh that sounds
good I'm talking to this cat and I had a
with him like shortly after Oh without
he didn't know about it until my
publicist Richie Abbott was like so you
know that you were the inspiration
behind fraud she's like what I'm at a
humongous technine fan so when I got
there I had like my mask on and
everything you know I had on a
transparent mask we met somewhere off
Venice Beach in a restaurant I walked in
everybody's looking at me like I'm about
to rob the mask you aware for why that
plastic yo-yo said it was that day I
okay yeah I was drunk and everything I'm
hard not got a really good interview
yeah so I walked in and he's like first
of all they misprinted I'm like yeah
they always you know but he was cool
yeah you know saying but I'm like I'm
not one of these guys that do music and
you know just to you know I don't know
I'm just not I'm the under kind of dude
that I feel my music I'll write it I
feel it so when you critique it I want
you to sit with it before you know a lot
of people try to listen to a CD like one
pad I can't stand when people put out
their little reviews like the daddy
outcomes
two weeks they've got a live with it man
two weeks and then come back because
then they'll come back saying they sorry
but they said something about nas's
album when they sat down and listened to
it like wow this is really great play
but we can have later like that's when
you should do your thing
and I told you I told them people if
you're gonna say something about me just
expect me to come back I am a boss for
one you know I'm sent our own strange
music you know saying and I am an artist
so I have both you know I mean I I know
how to get to these people and get their
numbers from my publicist and find
people you know what I mean so I'm gonna
like why did you say this you know I
mean why didn't you holla at me before
you know and they probably ain't used to
that but I've truly filled my music and
I put so much in it that I want that
love back I expect that love better
because I give all of me that's the
whole thing uh every tour whenever I
know that you know you're gonna be
announcer that's why I always look
forward to seeing who who the support is
gonna be because you know you've had MGK
you've had paul wall you've had this
time around it's crazy because my to
like favorite rappers
last three or four years have been ribs
and have been Freddie Gibbs yeah you
side Ritz yeah and now Gibbs is on the
toes Gibbs is on the tour man and he's
doing wonderfully man this is our
seventh show out of 78 and yeah what
brought you to put kids on the tour well
I've been knowing Gibbs for a while man
we've been seeing each other for like
four and five years you know I'm saying
like doing our little promotional tours
and stuff in New York and this they're
not always bumped into him at MTV and we
exchanged numbers back then when I'm in
his town I'll hit him but he's always
traveling but he's never in town we
always kept he was always a stand-up cat
yeah so when they brought his name to me
and me being up on his gangster music
you know I'm saying it was like when
they said what do you think about
Freddie Gibbs I'm like yes that's my boy
let's go I mean it didn't matter you
know I'm saying so because it's slim dog
you know saying when it comes to hip-hop
you know who did who the tour with my
fans there they boost your fans around
slam you know we got this big as we
think about so I don't know slam dude
you know everybody's doing a thing
already like schoolboy q is doing his
thing yeah I'm so was doing this thing
j-rock is doing this thing Kendrick
Lamar is doing his thing you know what
I'm saying Travis Gambino is doing his
thing you know I'm saying Lupe
everybody's doing anything you don't
mean so it's hard to try to lock it you
know me and Wayne been talking about a
tour for like two years now you know
saying but it's hard to get to bosses in
the same spot at the same time so it's
it's slim you know they're like oh
travers give me a list I'm like uh-huh
man I mean you know family it was
sounding more appealing
before they came up with Gibbs and Jaron
it sounded more appealing going on with
um
Five Finger Death Punch right probably
make more sense yeah yeah yeah you know
I'm saying and they trying to do it in
November and I'm like that how we gonna
do that and still service Europe and put
it out we trying to figure it out right
now you know I'm stance because the rock
world is knocking since I put out
therapy yeah people have been paying
attention to me and searched honking and
doing music and stuff and me and the
doors so it's like it was more building
you know Zam but then when they said
what you think about free gears and Jen
I'm like yes makes sense like wardrobe
is you know Stan Nick Cannon came to
Kansas City and he brought them to the
show to our show on the last tour
October 30th
we bonded you know it's like we're
druggies fit perfectly with crazy tec-9
yeah of course there goes the tour along
with Chris calico